dhamaka Sunday stands for nice price
dependable cars although not says our
car review or Sasha for exciting ones
the car makers set out to change that
image in 2013 with a coupe a version for
the i30 but it didn't really set
automotive hearts on fire not least
because of the engines available at the
time they've now been upgraded as part
of a facelift Sasha recalls Hyundai and
joined perhaps the ultimate accolade for
the regular I 30 Martin vinta corn then
CEO of the Volkswagen Group nice and
smooth the coop a edition of that
top-selling Hyundai was created at its
European design and development center
in whistles I'm it comes with three
gasoline and two diesel engines we
checked out the most powerful diesel
version with a direct shift gearbox
official fuel consumption is four point
two liters for 100 kilometers sasha is
driving the 110 kilowatt diesel version
even if the specs don't quite seem to
work out in reality this engine together
with a dual clutch transmission give you
a certain flow bordering on the sporty
the trick is not to fully depress the
gas if you do the transmission will just
shift down three speeds and the engine
will get hysterical if you only push the
pedal two-thirds of the way down the
transmission will gradually shift
upwards and you can really enjoy it li
ste students all on the Holden Vic woman
Cliff Lee teach pasta
does faith lifters the facelift was
primarily on the technical front explain
Sasha there's an array of assist
features including a park assist it
costs extra so Sasha wants to see if
it's worth it bastia tatsächlich um it's
activated at the push of a button the
system then tells the driver what to do
or rather what not to do you do have to
keep to a snail's pace otherwise the car
will turn off the assist parking is
pretty straightforward even for
beginners and the system is very
intuitive that said it takes a lot more
than two moves the i30 likes to be
precise and therefore takes its time
the podcast in the assist is only truly
helpful if you're a really poor Parker
reckon Sasha and on city streets other
road users might get a bit impatient so
you might find them getting a little hot
under the collar and the assist only
works when parallel parking for all
other forms of parking spaces you have
to guide the vehicle in yourself once
you've found and taken a space watch
your doors in the new i30 Kupe there's
17 centimeters longer than with the
regular version that makes getting into
the rear seats easier but when you're
getting out the door swings out further
so sasha is now going to repark the same
pockets on the mole it's easier when
there are no cars next to you of course
oh yes absolutely so now even sasha has
enough space to take a seat and the rear
the idea so nice little entry could be
more elegant but you do have a
relatively generous amount of space both
legroom and Headroom and the safety belt
holder is a nice touch to invited longer
doors mean the b-pillar is so far back
that you'd otherwise have to lean a long
way behind yourself to build up I'm
Elijah itself infants they would
calouste whats coop the coop hey matches
the cargo space of the regular five-door
edition 378 litres just two liters less
than a gulf and when you fold down the
rear bench it increases to 1316 leaders
the coop pays front is based
structurally on the five-door edition
which you can see and that affiliation
has its benefits the 5-door version got
a five star rating for the Euro NCAP
crash test so occupants of the three
door model also enjoy maximum protection
from a head-on collision
there's little change in the interior
and why should there be nice and smooth
the workmanship is very satisfactory
everywhere
Oh miss lemon the former VW bosh was
right nice and smooth and that also
applies to the facelift it's not quite
as exciting as Hyundai might have wished
but it is a solid package and those are
the qualities that appeal the customers
they're good uncle